28 років працювали на ринку міста Москви
відвідували місця позбавлення волі
ви самі говорили навіть із цими хто
обвинувачений у тяжких статтях за тероризм
який випадок чи яка розмова вам
запам'ятався найбільше ось за ці
вісім років мене дуже вразило нагоді
олега Сєнцова це кінорежисер
українські, яку посадили за звинуваченням
у тероризмі в тому, що він хотів нібито
підірвати в криму пам'ятник леніну
абсолютно не було жодних доказів
і його посадили тільки за те, що він був
проти анексії крима це людина
яка була активна в криму в
Сімферополі і значить була якась
група людей які ось були проти
анексії крима також він допомагав
українським військовим виїжджати з криму та
рівно за це його посадили на мене
вразив цей чоловік тим, що він його
страшно катували його, змушували визнати
свою провину він не визнав свою провину
а разом із ним ще посадили трьох людей
та двоє
під тортурами визнали провину в тому, що вони
брали участь разом з ним у цих спробах
терактів і його обмовили ось і я ходив до
йому в лефортівській в'язниці та
дивовижна історія що чому мені ще
так це лефортівської в'язниці
вона мені так от сильно зачепила тому
що 8 другому році моя мама сиділа в цьому
ж в'язниці і мені навіть показували камеру
де вона сиділа і виявився що олег
сінців сидить у цій самій камері ось і
все таке б якусь дежа вю та ось і
чим у мене вразив випадку сенцова що
зовсім неможливо було йому допомогти
тому що довести те, що він не
винний він не зміг перебуває зараз сови
і шматки і ви правильно сказали що це
викликало широкий суспільний резонанс
так само як і справи савченка так само як і
справи павленського та дадина та цих трьох
людей випустили під тиском
громадськості зокрема до чого
сенцовым ось це не працює наскільки я
чула що для путіна та сінців це крим
а.к.
для путіна це така проблема та це як
б справа і у всьому житті до останніх років
життя і тому якщо той що якщо вас не
відпустить ні за що не будуть дуже
сильно торгуватися що я не не знаю
за що його як можна продати у лапках
до цього сенців за що путін його віддасть